c'est une petite révolution qui vient de
se dérouler dans la porcherie de
Matthieu pilote propriétaire de la ferme
familiale depuis plus de 5 ans le
producteur de Charlevoix a réaménagé ses
installations pour se conformer aux
nouvelles normes de bien-être animal
avant on avait l'intrus qui était tout
en logette toute leur vie il y avait
accès à l'eau la nourriture mais il y
avait un petit espace d'environ 14 pieds
carrés
pour s'exprimer toute leur vie à compter
de 2029 les producteurs de port du
Canada devront élever leurs truies en
groupe comme ici c'est ce que prévoit
une mise à jour du code de pratique de
l'industrie dont l'adhésion est en
principe facultative mais les
producteurs qui ne se conforment pas
seront incapables de vendre leur cochons
dans les abattoirs notre transformateur
nous disent que il y a de plus en plus
de marché que ils vont y exigent détruit
en groupe pour accepter les animaux pour
accepter à bien c'était comme ça comme
vous voyez là partout mais ce ne sera
pas la fin des cages de gestation pour
autant après leur insémination les
truies pourront passer jusqu'à 5
semaines dans des Stales une façon de
réduire les risques de fausses couches
une gestation ça dure 120 jours ça veut
dire que les premiers 35 jours
au Canada c'est encore légal puis c'est
assez énorme là que j'ai répondu de les
laisser en stand individuel ensuite de
ça faut casser en groupe pour la majeure
partie de sa gestation aller jusqu'à 115
jours ensuite de ça un retour dans une
falaise pour mettre bon
avec les nouvelles normes détruits
seront confinés dans des cages pendant
la moitié de leur vie environ plutôt
qu'en totalité selon ce spécialiste du
comportement des ports au centre de
recherche fédéral de Sherbrooke il n'y a
aucun doute l'élevage en groupe et de
loin préférable pour le bien-être des
animaux étui peuvent se déplacer peuvent
se retourner donc ça leur permet d'avoir
cette liberté de mouvement et d'exprimer
les comportements aussi plus facilement
que d'être pris dans un espace qui est
très exiguë fort c'est des animaux
sociaux qui cherchent le contact des
autres donc elle ça leur permet d'avoir
des contacts sociaux entre elles je vous
dirais que les animaux sont plus calmes
un peu un peu moins anxieux il y a un
envers en médaille
[Musique]
on estime que 55% des quelques 290 000
truies du Québec sont déjà élevés en
groupe Mathieu pilote a investi 450 000
dollars pour moderniser ses bâtiments et
installer un système automatisé pour
s'assurer que toutes les truies ont
accès à la même quantité de nourriture
il a aussi du réduire son cheptel sans
quoi une agrandissement aurait été
nécessaire on avait une capacité de 325
oui il faut comprendre qu'on a été
obligé de descendre à 288 oui pour être
capable de le faire à l'intérieur des
murs si j'avais pas mis d'automatisation
puis de gestion de troupeau en plus pour
essayer d'aller chercher une certaine
rentabilité mettre les truites en pack
en soit c'est 0 rentable
les producteurs n'ont pas le choix la
pression est de plus en plus forte elle
vient des acheteurs et des consommateurs
mais aussi des groupes de défense des
animaux selon eux les nouvelles normes
ne vont pas assez loin ils auraient dû
entrer en vigueur l'année prochaine tel
que prévu au départ en réponse au
pression de l'industrie ça a été encore
prolongée jusqu'à 2029 à notre avis
c'est beaucoup trop long et il y a aussi
des trous d'exception qui sont prévus
même dans les nouvelles normes parce que
justement on peut continuer à garder les
truies dans ces cages là 35 jours
d'énormes similaires à celles qui seront
appliquées au Canada dans six ans sont
déjà en place depuis 2013 au sein de
l'Union européenne et certains pays ont
agi bien avant en Suède par exemple
l'utilisation de cage est complètement
bannie depuis 1988 10 étant américains
l'ont aussi fait où sont en voie de le
faire 10 hectares comme par exemple la
Californie l'Arizona etc
c'est sûr que ce sont pas les États qui
sont les plus gros producteurs de port
c'est à dire que la yowa par exemple
ou encore le ministre sont des États qui
produisent beaucoup de porcs la Caroline
du Nord ont pas mis en place des
législations comme celle-là donc dans
ces états-là les traits en cage sont
toujours autorisés
les producteurs d'ici Kring donc que du
port américain soit vendu un meilleur
prix sur le marché canadien si on a un
coût de production qui est plus élevé
puis que les consommateurs ne sont pas
prêts à le payer puis qui choisissent
plutôt la viande d'un autre pays ben on
rend service à personne ça fait imposer
des normes qu'on dit plus humaine par
des humains qui ont jamais travaillé
avec les animaux c'est un peu
contradictoire et ce n’est sans doute
pas le dernier changement qui sera
réclamé ou producteur la castration des
porcelets qui est pratiquée pour que la
viande est meilleure goût restera
permise au Canada même chose pour la
collectomie c'est-à-dire couper la queue
des cochons pour éviter qu'il mordille
celle du voisin et qu'elle s'infecte une
analgésie requise pour les deux
procédures mais pas d'anesthésie ça a
été documenté scientifiquement que c'est
très douloureux comme procédure alors la
seule façon de supprimer totalement
c'est de pas castrer et c'est ce qui se
fait de plus en plus en Europe
pour Mathieu pilote le passage à
l'élevage de groupe a été difficile vous
aurez parlé après deux mois je vous
aurais dit ça va très mal mais on
s'habitue au système puis les animaux on
a enlevé les animaux qui étaient plus
vieux il a finalement ça va mieux
il espère que les consommateurs vont
comprendre que les producteurs ont à
coeur le bien-être de leurs animaux mais
qu'ils veulent aussi être capable de
gagner leur vie
[Musique]